hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my non-spoilery Mission Impossible
rogue nation review if you haven't seen
any of them before this is actually the
fifth Mission Impossible film I know
that sounds kind of weird the first one
dropped way back in the 90s and then
they've actually they come a long way in
the franchise you know both in their
filmmaking technique and in the way they
portray their characters Tom Cruise is
definitely a racehorse he beats the crap
out of himself in the name of
entertainment he's one of those few
actors that demands that he do a lot of
his own stunts whenever you go see it in
the theater just consider that he's
tearing himself apart in the name of fun
that's that's really why he does a lot
of this stuff like a lot of people are
talking about top gun too he said the
only reason that he would come back to
that franchise is if they could actually
use real jets in the film like Mike no
cgt jets like he's all about having fun
and if we were as powerful as him like
wouldn't we do the same thing I feel
like he is like the ultimate youtuber
where it's like he just he quits his job
and has fun and films it and then it
just turns into like 150 million dollar
movies so he's living like 150 million
dollar version of like what I'm trying
to get to talk about really awesome
stuff make a lot of friends on the
internet make a whole lot of really fun
videos the only difference is i'm
working with like zero dollars and I
didn't throw my selves out of any
windows or jump onto any planes so if
you've seen the trailers they tell you a
little bit about what the story is they
they mostly sell the stunts which is
what this movie is it's like one giant
stunt with a huge water slide in the
middle it could legitimately turn this
movie into a theme park I always give
him like an A+ for stunts but what about
the storing the actors well let's start
with the actors first because a lot of
people forget Mission Impossible is a
big Hollywood franchise but it involves
a lot of other big actors that are part
of giant franchises like we have Hawkeye
and we have Scotty from Star Trek
sometimes you forget that Jeremy
Renner's part of this franchise he
doesn't get any bows and arrows but he
does have a lot of fun simon Pegg's the
real comedian though but if you enjoyed
him in Ghost Protocol he like he takes
it to the next level in this film like
he's always arguing about how he is a
field agent he wants to go out and like
do stuff in the field just like Ethan
Hunt does Tom Cruise is always going to
get the best thoughts but Simon pay gets
a lot of the biggest laughs in the film
ving rhames even comes back for the
party he's a lot of fun too he's a
fairly minor presence in the film I feel
like he kind of maxed out of
the first two films and then you know
they brought in like Jeremy Renner and
Simon Pegg they're much bigger actors so
naturally they're going to focus a lot
more on those characters but he wasn't
just like a token inclusion and speaking
of like minor characters Alec Baldwin
has a really fun part to play he's a
little off type like you really see why
they cast him because you get this sense
based on like his public perception that
he's not that nice of a guy so like
whenever they cast him in a movie
they're they're looking for him to
either be like a villain or just someone
who's a total in the movie kind
of plays on that trope a little bit it
kind of subverts your expectations the
newcomer is Rebecca Ferguson most of you
may not have seen her before she was in
that Hercules movie that the rock made
which which wasn't that good I wouldn't
I wouldn't recommend watching that but
she was also part of this really good TV
series called the white queen so if you
want to see more from her it's not an
action role but it's a really good
period drama of the War of the Roses
it's called the white queen after seeing
her in that and then seeing her in rogue
nation I feel like she just spent like
an entire year in the gym just turning
herself into a badass of all the women
in all the Mission Impossible films she
is my new favorite what they do is they
kind of elevate her to the superhero
level of Ethan Hunt good enough to run
circles around him on a bike if you
watched the first tube Mission
Impossible films I feel like those films
are a lot of fun but they're terrible
with their female characters so if you
want to watch really awesome females I
mean just stick to ghost Protocol and
rogue nation although of the two rogue
nation is even better you have to
remember this is a movie all about
statecraft so it you know there's a lot
of espionage and politics going on in
the background but that never like bogs
down the film like they never spent too
much time having to explain stuff it's
mostly a visual experience remember that
simon Pegg's character and ving rhames
are both like the tech based characters
they get to play with a lot of really
cool toys there's a lot of really
awesome complicated sets but the logic
hoops that they make you jump through
like never take you out of the film that
was one of the biggest complaints of
mission impossible 3 the one the one
that JJ Abrams had like a really big
hand in making there was this thing
called the rabbit's foot at the end of
the film it was as big MacGuffin like
this really important thing that they
never explained like it just it just
kind of trailed off into the distance
stories need mcguffin's like they need
something to drive the plot forward but
they can't just like drop it like you
can't turn into nothing this film plays
with that a little bit it does a good
job
like playing with a lot of the tropes of
the series like the Mission Impossible
film series in general it references
stuff all the way back from the first
film in a way that's important to the
plot but but also for comedy and it just
has some fun with the idea of that
rabbit's foot MacGuffin so just you keep
your eyes peeled for rabbit's feet I
think my favorite thing about the film
is that like the self-reflexive way in
which it treats the the IMF the
impossible mission force you know like
the group of people that the Tom
Cruise's character belongs to it's
almost like this movie treats the IMF
like the studio treated Tom Cruise a
couple years ago when ever tried to fire
him from the movies if you remember
whenever he was you know he was jumping
on Oprah's couch and he was getting a
lot of bad press about Scientology the
studio tried to fire him from the
Mission Impossible series but they were
unsuccessful and he went on to make
mission impossible 4 and 5 they ended up
making a dump truck of money and
everything turned out fine the movie has
a little bit of fun with that I actually
I wonder if when they were in the script
phase they were actually talking about
that I always feel like big movie
studios are really happy to laugh at
themselves when they're wrong when they
make a bad call but everything turns out
all right okay yeah we were wrong to try
and fire you you've got more staying
power than ever because that's really
what you come out of this movie feeling
like Tom Cruise can make two or three
more Mission Impossible films it's
almost like that you know thanks to a
little bit of movie technology and him
keeping himself in shape he is
functionally immortal from a movie
standpoint so here's my big question for
you guys if you have had a chance to see
the movie what's your favorite part
about it you know like what was your
favorite stunt and where do you want to
see them go in the next film because
they will definitely be a next film just
remember that a lot of people probably
haven't seen the movie yet so please use
spoiler tags if you're going to talk
about like specific plot things but if
you guys want i will do like a spoiler
version to this tomorrow either way it's
a lot of fun be sure and go see it I
didn't see it in 3d I thought I'd just
like a regular print of the film it was
fine so just in general without getting
like into really spoilery specific
moments I'll give this movie an aid for
the stunts amazing stunts in a B+ for
this story like it's a really exciting
story and it leaves the franchise in a
good place like a strong place to go
into the next movie with Rebecca
Ferguson coming back I feel like that's
what a lot of the previous films lack is
that they don't have female characters
that are strong enough you know from a
story
and point to survive to the next film
whenever a movie rights like a female
character out of the story it's
essentially telling you that she's not
part of the core team she's not
important enough to come back so maybe
that's part of the reason why I really
liked Rebecca Ferguson's character so
much because she has this really complex
relationship with Tom Cruise's character
and they lead things with a lot of
potential they give you they give you
all the clues that you need to guess
like what's going to happen next so even
though Tom Cruise has been doing his own
stunts for like the last 20 or 30 years
I definitely give her an A for her
stunts in the film too I should say her
character stunts because I don't know if
she actually did her own stunts or not
probably not as much as Tom Cruise did
usually they don't let big actors do
that I think my favorite stunts from the
film were the airplane stunts like him
trying to get in the door that's in the
trailer and him jumping off that giant
high dive into the huge cooling tube so
I've got a couple other exciting things
happening this weekend there's some
Deadpool red band coming next week so
I'm going to be doing some Deadpool
tomorrow while you guys wait for all
that stuff you can click here to learn
all about Game of Thrones eighth season
plan they just didn't confirmed eight
seasons in a prequel and you can click
here to learn all about the blue flash
on the flash season 2 thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tomorrow
you